(upbeat music)
- Here's a little weekday motivation
from someone who inspires us.
- Hey friends, it is Karamo here
with your Motivational Minute.
Listen, Drew and I have talked about this
and something we believe
in, which is hooking in.
It's about finding those moments
and like, to really hold tight onto
and believe in yourself and trust
that you have what it takes
to make the moments that you
want and that you deserve.
Hook in, hook into those
moments that feel uncomfortable,
hook into those conversations
that seem uncomfortable,
because in those moments, you'll
have the most growth ever.
Believe in yourself, trust in yourself.
And if you doubt yourself, that's okay,
because you have the
ability to ask for help.
- Now, that was inspiring.
(upbeat music)